that was me there that was in 1975 how
times have changed how much I've changed
on which we've all changed as part of
his mentoring program
Ashanti travels to prisons throughout
Louisiana including Angola how you are
doing today one of the reasons I chose
this path was because I spent so much
time in Angola you know I left a lot of
friends behind I want to be in a
position where I could see them where I
can feel them where they can see me but
they can feel me feel my presence and be
in a position where I can possibly be of
help to them and some of the
relationships that were developed in
here were solid
returning angle is a lot like coming
home but it's a home where I don't have
to live it anymore it's two places
you're gonna find true friendship one is
in military during wartime because
everyone has to watch out for everyone
a prison setting such as had gold when
Ashanti and I came to a rock I mean
we're in Paris at the same time I'm
trying to gather you it was my brothers
in the Promotora Kelly's today would he
leave uh-huh is it a little bit harder
not not not no no no my heart would be
feeling good because I got a chance to
see him spend a little time with him and
see I'm saying and I know that he's
doing the same thing out there that he
was doing here he's looking to step
higher see I'm saying that's one thing I
was in my about Sunday you always look
to step hi compassion for people what's
good here has he's always looking for
the positive
I got it that's one thing I won't miss
do I gotta go counter I'll be right back
prison is very much a part of my life
because I'm involved with prison
ministry and I work with a number of the
inmates as working towards trying to
help them get out of prison but it no
it's not a distant memories is that
still very much a part of my life I went
in at the age of 22 and I was released
when I was 50 the bullets still in my
head I have to speak with the plate
staff to speak with this in my mouth
because there's a large bullet hole
which shows the passageway you can't
allow the situations in the world around
you to influence you in any kind of a
negative way because if they do the only
person who's gonna lose is you